[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you tapped into the group chat live in
the bleacher report app
presented by fanduel my name is cathy
richards the truth serum is always
coursing through her veins
that is our betting expert kelly stewart
and even though he's from the bay
he's our certified lover boy that is
greg ivory
uh listen with all the chatter on on
twitter about
potential versus matchups this year the
versus matchup that always produces a
banger
is chuck versus america we go
head-to-head against the great charles
barkley
each week in our segment chuck versus
america and um
we're doing pretty good on monday we
asked you which team would win the race
to 10 points phoenix or
or memphis we all decided to rival
phoenix
us is a squad and you guys is the
audience charles decided to
fade us and uh here's what happened the
prop bet for tonight
first to ten points in this uh memphis
phoenix game
i would take the memphis grizzlies don't
listen to chuck he's two and two
i i'll take the memphis grizzlies
again eight right in the middle of the
play this time booker can't get it to go
ayton secures it
javon carter hits a three
the teddy is back javon carter well done
sir nice
splash right there um so we we rocked
with the suns we improved to
6-0 against charles rocker let's maybe
we see please see the graphic
and the leaderboard we're five and oh
excuse me i got a little ahead of myself
because i'm excited for tonight's
matchup which we'll get to
in just a few moments so we are three
games ahead
of charles barkley and as long as
america is leading
we're leading and greg ivory is leading
the league and giving away hoodies
g-money get two of my brother
cabbie you know what time it is man
you guys know what time it is this is
the handy dandy ipod i am in
the comments i mean i call it an ipod
it's the ipad
right yeah man it's a lot going on
uh but anyway anyway i'm in the comments
man giving away hoodies looking for
takes
mooch wob braun
and a.d coming for their mvp
and defensive player of the year says
they're showing up today
shouts out to you you're walking away
with a hoodie
kade lee hayden lee says
is it playing for anyone i believe he's
talking about
the uh the show hopefully it's planned
for you guys
shouts out to you kaden i just want to
give you a hoodie because i like your
your your username cabbie i got one more
i got one more here we go this is live
this is live i'm reading these as they
come i got
i got matthew colt i think it's co
pete's or whatever producer you got it
i got lebron 30 plus five
three pointers wow does it turn back the
clock night tonight yeah
get the box or or what i don't know
what it is uh but shout out to matthew
he's walking away with a hoodie
i appreciate the confidence manual let's
get to the bed let's get to this week's
chuck versus america bet so
uh earlier today we asked you on social
who's gonna score more points tonight in
the lakers versus bucks game
lebron james the four-time mvp or
giannis antetokounmpo
the two-time mvp and reigning mvp
let's just let's check out the twitter
results right now the polls at 52
lebron wow it is a close one this is the
closest poll we've had so far
uh on the group chat brown in the lead
52 to 48 um
the greek god has had back-to-back
30-point games lebron hasn't hit 30
points so far
yet this season but with that said greg
ivory where are you leaning between the
mvp sir
cabbie my mind is telling me one thing
but then my heart is telling me the
other
so with that being said uh i'm gonna ask
the audience that you guys are gonna
have to help me
decide this one get in the comments let
me know
who we are riding with will it be lebron
will it be giannis let me know just just
just comment in the comments i got y'all
i'm giving away hoodies man
all right well let's let's let's check
in with our resident expert here
kellyanne stewart i don't know if ann is
the middle name but you know whatever
kelly melissa stewart where are you
leading tonight
uh lebron james or giannis antetokounmpo
to score the
to out out duel the other person gabby's
bringing back old school stuff from like
over a year ago
uh all jokes aside look i i
have to disagree with america here i
understand lebron plus money
looks really appealing but this is
lebron james we're talking about you
guys right now
my dude is on cruise control why because
he's already got june in his brain
he's not trying to like go out and ball
out in milwaukee tonight where
as opposed to giannis he is
the bucks need to win this game the
bucks are a short favor tonight i do
like the bucks tonight thus i like
giannis am i gonna lay 215 with them no
but
i think lebron plus 164 looks like a
trap
[Laughter]
i think i'm riding with america tonight
and lebron because i think he's still
salty from losing the mvp
to giannis last year and you know
big credit and salute to g-money's
golden state warriors who came back from
19 points on monday
and beat la in la so there's got to be a
little bit of that
salt in the wounds for the lakers so i
feel like brony
braun's gonna ball out tonight g-money
are you with me and
where is it where is the audience
leaning with kelly and the greek god
or uh me and braun cabby i'm all over
the place
i got multiple screens multiple comments
coming at me
but it's okay it is okay i got evan
on youtube shout out to youtube evan
says uh
evan says king james king james brother
uh my guy killabeezy is saying
king james all the way i got
victor victor is saying giannis come on
now
uh all of you guys i'm giving you guys
hoodies dm me greg underscore ivory i
got you i promise you i'll give you guys
the hoodie
uh but cabbie uh i i i think
the audience is unfortunately rocking
with lebron
okay well listen the twitter poll was at
52 to 48
for lebron james it sounds like in the
comments people are rocking with braun
you know i mean kelly knows he is a
facilitator and at times a triple double
threat and maybe he's on cruise control
but maybe he's not tonight so we will
see
um america so check out the pre-game
show the iconic inside the nba
for how charles barkley is going to ride
tonight
will he be with us at rock and roll
lebron james or will he be riding
with giannis onsen takumpo make sure you
check out fanduel
um for the link to the sorry for
and bet excuse me the head to head match
bet
head to head match bet lebron giannis
tonight
and uh don't forget to send us your
videos to be featured on the show
celebrants celebratory or or either way
now let's talk three by two three by two
is a quick hitter bet that we invented
and we are in love with and
we're also 6-0 so the question is
will there be two three-pointers in the
first three minutes
of the game will there be two
three-pointers made in the first three
minutes
of the game and tonight we're looking at
we're gonna stay in
lakers versus bucks because this game is
box office
so uh g-money you celebrate you
celebrated i believe
five or six straight three by twos
because we've been on a tear
and you've been celebrating celebrating
with with the homie mikey locks who's
also in the group chat
uh where are you leaning tonight homie
is it happening
or nah cabbie
to be honest i want to write yes just
because you know i'm all about the vibes
but this one just
you know i don't know cabbie i got to go
to the audience i got to go tap it with
my guys in youtube
shout out to the youtube uh people
that's watching on youtube
tap into my guys on the handy dandy ipad
i need sunsets i need
uh i i need yeses i need no's i need
help from you guys
to help clear my mind and get me in the
direction
that we should be riding today because
uh we are gonna be riding
must believe we're gonna be riding but
you guys let me know
kelly what do you think though shout out
to kelly man what do you
talk to the people you think we're gonna
uh hit this 3x2
greg we just spoke about this last week
look at no point in time am i stepping
in front of this freight train until it
starts losing
i feel like this was like a gift from
the fan dual betting gods right
they let us create this bet and then
we're just gonna keep
winning it we want to give our audience
some free money i'm riding yes until the
wheels fall off
kelly i'm right there with you i i
leaned no last week and i got burned
i'm back on the yes train milwaukee's
become like a volume shooting
three-point team
and they start right away drew holiday
brook lopez
chris middleton and on the other side
kcp has been a very reliable
score from distance for la so i believe
in the first two minutes of this lakers
bucks game
definitely gonna hit two three-pointers
g-money has the audience
tapped in where are they leaning on this
one
shouts out to everybody on youtube
tapping in man
shouts out to everybody on youtube shout
out to people that's on the app tapping
and i'm loving this double screen
double comments y'all give me more
comments that's more hoodies right
that's true yes all right here we go i'm
in the comments and i got
aaron aaron engler says of course
why not he's riding with us i got
binobino bino says no question he says
no question
that means he's riding with us i got one
more cabbie
got geico got geico gives me a yes
with like 15 s's so therefore
we are riding with the yes make sure you
guys
check us out on the live where you guys
can ride with us
me and my guy mikey locks mikey i see
you in the comments too brother
we will be going live on the vr
instagram handle let's go i'm juiced
about this
i i look forward to that celebration
tonight running down the street
sunset vibes all day check out our br
betting social channels to get the link
for the 3x2 offered by fanduel it's the
only place
that you can get us so salute to our
friends at fanduel and as always
send us your videos or enjoy the one
that g money and mikey locks
are going to make tonight cole anthony
hit
a beautiful game winner last night ahead
nba twitter buzzing
had a great reaction from his dad greg
anthony on the uh mb on t
uh nba tv broadcast lamella ball
outdueled his brother lonzo earlier in
the year and james wiseman threw down
like 37 dunks
last night as the warriors took care of
business we have to talk about the
rookie of the year
future bet because the rook of the year
race
i mean it's early in the season but it's
heating up may we see the graphic please
we got lamellar ball right at the top
minus 190 i mean
that's a lot of juice tyrese halliburton
balling out there in sacramento
plus 300 anthony was the number one
overall pick plus
1300 and james wiseman the
aforementioned at plus 1600.
the uh the list gets a little bit longer
the odds get a little bit longer as we
go down there but
definitely some talented young ballers
in the mix
uh g-money have you booked your futures
rookie of the year bet
and if so who are you putting money on
or who have you
look at the look on my face right here
cabbie
i'll let you know who i'm betting in a
minute but look at the look on my face
lamelo ball minus
190 to win the uh the win the rookie of
the year
oh wait hold on hold on i need cap or no
cap in the comments we got youtube
comments
we got the br app comments cap or no cap
should lamelo be the favorite to win the
uh ricky of the year this year with that
much juice that's a lot of juice that's
almost two dollars abby
that's almost two dollars i need the
comments to let me know cap or no cap
before i give you guys my take
but kelly i know you're itching
i know you're itching give your take
tell them talk to them
while i uh dive into these comments well
the guy that i like is way too far on
the list they didn't even put him on the
graphic and that's bull bull
i think he has an outside shot here uh
uh also who doesn't just love to say
bull bull
anyway all jokes aside greg to answer
your question about lamelo he's minus
190 for a reason
i do believe he is in the driver's seat
to win
rookie of the year if he stays healthy
and if he's able to contribute to his
team better than other rookies the
problem is
i don't think his team is going to make
a big splash
this season a team i do think is going
to make a big splash and did last night
is your team the warriors of course
everybody's looking at steph curry but
as cabbie just alluded to to start this
segment james wiseman
has been playing his tail off you gotta
love it
he is uh my pick at 16-1
i'm right there with you cass like even
though lamelo ball already has a
triple-double in his young career and
his highlights and his passing are
spectacular
it's understandable he's at the top of
the list but like you kel's james
wiseman
he's on national the golden state
warriors are on national tv
as much as the lakers so that means that
the nba voters will get to see as
they're looking at steph curry
while the crowd's dropping 62 points
every now and then
wiseman's gonna get a lot of looks and
he's learning from draymond
he's gonna get a lot of uh easy bunnies
at the rim and the golden state wars are
probably to kelly's point
going to make the playoffs so if a
rookie can help his team make the
playoffs
i think that's favorable in his case for
rookie of the year but that's just me
okay so gmod you have to explain your
look with the is it cap or no cap that
lamelo
it's back and forth i got two screens in
front of me it's back and forth
uh on the app it seems like they're
saying uh
i see a lot of cap i see cap shouts out
to deep geek
uh shouts out to big mike 13. he said no
cap with a lot of sunsets you're walking
away with a hoodie brother
uh let me shift focus over to youtube
where i see a
whole bunch of cap in the comments we
might break a youtube record today
uh i see cap soccer soccer 10
ma71c says cap enderman gaming says
cap the swami 520 says cap
jerry kingsbury says cap cabbie i can
keep going i have two screens in front
of me you want me to keep going i'm just
waiting
everybody i said they're giving they're
getting a hoodie too by the way
everybody i said they're getting a
hoodie i just can't believe that
reaction like lamello's got a couple of
double doubles i mean
the kid is just electric on the court
kathy let me make let me make my point
let me make my point
so please when we're talking about the
rookie of the year
we're just not talking about the player
that's why you guys don't focus we
you can't just look at the player you
gotta look at the team
you gotta look at the team we know the
warriors are gonna go
to the playoffs we'll say that i'll make
that we know the warriors are going to
go to the playoffs so i think
that's going to play into the voting
towards the end of the season
so with that being said no i'm not being
a homer
i'm not being a homer i'm using a little
logic here
the warriors are going to get better
they're playing better uh
wiseman just said yesterday that
draymond green's like his big brother
they're meshing
their chemistry is coming together it's
gonna click i'm rocking with james
weisman and i see it in the comments too
a couple people
they said james weisman but they're all
over capped because uh
lamelo should not be almost two two
bills kelly
you know let's yeah listen it's early in
the season
right now he's coming off the bench
wiseman is a starter but that will most
certainly change in lamellae's case
as they're easing him into the rotation
and then man maybe we'll see a
another triple double but there's a long
time for that those are our uh rookie of
the year picks
and um that was a lot of fun my
my most favorite part of the of this
show other than the three by two
is this moment right here where our good
friend greg ivory
tries his hand at landing a five leg
single game parlay
i hope you have money in the bank greg
because kelly
if we if you keep trending in this
direction that 500 is gonna go to
kelly's venmo
and then i will enjoy a nice meal on
your behalf
alongside uh kelly kels all right so
uh before we get to you building this
single
game parley let's show you what a
winning ticket looks like
big salute to mr locksmith who landed a
monster single game parlay look at this
bad boy
it's 400 to 1 250 wager
100 grand 100 bands
like this is just incredible like that
is a shot in the dark
that landed boom right in the middle of
the target blew up the moon he should do
this
tired just beat him can we throw up the
rain give it back
can we throw out the real ticket please
okay so that's one ticket
now this is last week's second yeah it
looks a lot there's some
a lot more red on this ticket than the
real
the real ticket right there that's the
real ticket right there hey i was
uh go ahead go ahead kelly my bad
because i was just going to talk about
the producer real quick because i was
just
buttering him up on slack and then he
goes and throw
he throws the uh the the winning parlay
right before he shows my ticket man
i i see you max i see you
it's called sabotage so as we check the
ticket and checked my notes uh two for
five last week
you're you're aiming to get five for
five so g money what do you have for us
tonight in the new orleans pelicans game
versus new orleans pelicans versus utah
jazz
it's time for redemption kelly let me
pull out the old notes in my
phone right here because this is going
to tell me
who we are riding with here we go
starting it
off brandon
ingram over 21.5 points shouts out to my
guy luke from toronto
he gave me that one hey my guy luke i
shot him out every week because
he is the prop king he knows his props
uh shouts out to luke anyway we are
moving on
brandon ingram we're staying with him
because we gonna we
i see him having a game tonight cabbie
we're gonna go
over five and a half rebounds
i think that one's gonna be tight g
money no no no
he he's like a he's like a he's somewhat
similar to katie as far as in stature
tall
skinny you know he he's up there so i
can see him grabbing five
six rebounds six reruns we need six so i
can see him grabbing six
shout out to my guy dodger shout out to
my guy dodger
uh who's every weeks he's on the
winner's only rankings list
shout out to my guy dodger he tapped in
uh moving
on cabbie we got mike conley
over under cabbie take a guess well
mike conley and what though just
saying i'm gonna say i'm gonna say uh
over mike conley over point guard
oh guys have won six games in a row
they're cooking right now
shouts out to you over we're going with
the over
14 and a half points my guy money bag
captain you no money
i've seen him on punishment and then
i've also seen him
you know in the uh on on the rankings
where does he stand right now is he
still on punishment
it's a love hey it's a love hate
relationship in this on the winners only
team it's not too much hate though
it's just all playful hate but it's a
love eight but you know uh i think i
think money bags is on its way trending
back up the rankings we gotta see
but anyway let me get back to this
though let me get back to the matter at
hand
because we are moving on now the total
is sitting at 217.
we have utah and we have new orleans we
know new orleans like to get up and up
and down the court
so uh i'm rocking with the over in the
game total
let's go over 217. um
you yes kelly nothing i got nothing
never mind no county no
speak speak your piece this is the group
no
no no no kelly kelly's time's done with
that being said we're moving on to the
final leg of this one the final leg of
this one lonzo ball
kelly i'll let you speak over or under
of course you're gonna take the over
greg under
under under 10 and a half points shout
out to my
guy champ cheese he's a fireman i need
firemen locks in the comments
fireman locks in the comments my guy
champ cheese gave us that one
blondo ball under 10 and a half points
uh
the brendan ingram over like zion's
playing
steven adams is playing i know it's the
second game of a back to back
you know there's rudy gobert is in the
middle that guy eats more rebounds than
macaroons bro
then there's derrick favors like i don't
know
i know you're an optimist by nature but
that one's
to me in this single leg parlay the
brennan ingram over
to get six rebounds that's the tightest
one because
there are some big boys in that paint
can we show the ticket can we can we get
the ticket
shouts out to your analysis cabbie but i
don't want to hear it because we are
going to win
only you've seen the one
[Music]
kelly relax please read relax
15 to 1 you see we're going to turn that
uh
we're going to turn that that 50 into
about 750 700 something like that
that's cool it's a cool little sam you
know i mean uh
so yeah we gonna turn that 50 into sim
uh
y'all let me know y'all let me know in
the comments in the comments let me know
if y'all riding with the parlay show the
kids some love man show the kids some
love
kelly what you think about my parlay i
don't know i wasn't going to mess with
the total of the game tonight but i
guess i'm going to take the under now
[Laughter]
is it immediately fade greg are we is
that it is that what we're doing no
but now he's got no intrigue now he's
right it's fade kelly remember that's
what the commenters say
so but in all seriousness now when we
get off here i'm gonna have to go look
and be like okay maybe i do like that
under tonight
all right well listen uh has has the
audience i know you
you have your winners only wednesdays
and they help you build these single
game parlays but is there anybody else
in
in the audience or the commenters that
are riding with this particular ticket
or this
literally you should substitute one of
those legs out
literally cabbie yeah the comment is on
fire
i see a bunch of fire emojis because i
said firemen locked my guy champ cheese
he's a legend he's a legend my guy champ
cheese is a fireman
and a fireman locks i see a lot of fires
in the comments
uh look i i'm taking that that they're
rocking with my picks so i'm giving away
some hoodies
enderman gaming shouts out to you i see
like 17
fires uh a ron
risk greg is smart no cap shouts out to
you brother very smart by the way
here we go back into the comments i got
the ultimate the
ultimate says fire scott
brooks uh i don't know do i should i
give him a
that's bad bops no hoodie no hoodie here
we go we're moving on
we're moving on that's a different team
we're moving on we are moving on
i'm in i'm back into the app and i got
m-m-n-m-i-a-m
he's uh i don't know who i am shout-out
to dating yeah
he's saying everything he's fading
everything i do
oh no he's fading okay he said he's
riding but he's on the under
and total points and mike carly so he's
fading me i mean
i still show love i show love wherever i
show love so we're giving him a hoodie
cabbie i got one more i'm sorry if i'm
going long but i got one more it's just
so many comments so many screens
i love this i got miguel miguel espinoza
greg let me get a hoodie bro
shout out to you miguel you're walking
away with the hoodie my friend
he gave me fire emojis too cabbie so i
just didn't give him give him
the hoodie just for that take he gave me
fire emojis so shout out to you miguel
cabby i'm done i promise all right
hey miguel we adorn you homie and also
shout out to eminem i am who rocks with
us on the squad ride as well
appreciate you bro so listen uh thank
you very much to all the commenters
and the viewers for tapping into this
week's group chat presented by our
friends at fanduel
remember what you learned today ride
with america
versus chuck until the wheels fall off
the hit up the br socials for the link
to the 3x2
and thousand dollar parlays are
possible so good luck y'all alongside
kelly stewart
and greg aubry we are leaving the group
chat peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you